hi there
steve here and uh today is kind of an
unscheduled video
uh
because i would like some help
um
amwitat kum uh vorbesque limba romana
uh
um
[Music]
i'm forgetting my romanian
stories we have the mini story project
we've got i don't know 60 volunteers
translating into 30 languages we don't
have romanian these many stories are so
effective for my greek i want to do that
in romanian to get my romanian back
please if there's any people out there
native speakers of romanian that can
help us translate and record please let
me know send me an email steve at
link lingq dot com
apparently we're all so short uh check
so
either those languages but i think i'll
get the check because i'll be in
bratislava and there'll be some czech
people there and so i hopefully i can
twist some arms and get some check going
but romanian
that would be great
uh varog as i said i've forgotten at all
multi mask
um
yeah
another well i have the microphone here
uh my wife and i she discovered on
netflix this korean
drama series called president
and it's great it's a slightly
implausible plot but very clever very
interesting excellent acting
the quality of the photography is great
i mean it's not a high budget thing
everything is shot in the studio but we
really enjoy it and it's fun you know
the rewards of of learning a language uh
while there are english subtitles for my
wife and and me really to follow it
really well but i pick up a lot of it
and it was done in 2010 and yet a lot of
the issues there in this sort of
presidential election in korea
uh kind of remind me of what's happening
in states and france there's hacking
of uh you know uh private uh
you know websites of politicians there's
corrupt politicians
there's a grandstanding by politicians
politicians saying things that they know
they can't deliver on
uh what else was there there's reference
to a health system the guy is proposing
a health system for korea
and so a lot of the issues are very uh
much
relevant to today i have to say in
passing that i cannot understand
the kafil in the u.s over their health
system it is beyond my comprehension i
don't understand that people are covered
not covered i don't understand how you
can have
any kind of a comprehensive system if
you don't have everyone in it
and but anyway that's for them to work
out so uh
but i think i always feel
that i
think what however we do in society in
life
it's very much influenced by luck even
if you are hard working you inherited
those genes
uh if you were born into a wealthier
family or in a family where parents were
able to spend time with you and motivate
you to read books and do well in school
a lot of these things are a matter of
luck
and so given that luck is distributed so
unequally in our lives and yet every
like life is equally valuable
then i think any society that i want to
live in
tries to equalize the opportunities for
people
and
providing health care for everyone is
one of those ways in my opinion i feel
very strongly about that and i'm very
glad that however imperfect our system
here is in canada and uh i think it
could be a lot better and i think there
are better systems in other countries
but still i'm very glad we have it
anyway enough of that i'll get lots of
criticism now for uh using this podium
for political views but the next
regularly scheduled video will be on
language
and meanwhile if there are potential if
there are some people who are prepared
to volunteer for our project especially
romanian please let me know and thank
you for listening